welcome to this lecture
yeah so for this
it's for this edition of insane in the
endgame i'm stephen zerk
i'm the gm in residence for st louis
right now
and in this in this lecture
i'm going to cover a bishop against
knight end game by my all-time favorite
player
mahel tulf and in this game tall was
black
as we're going to see he has the bishop
against smith's love's knight
and so yeah in this position
right we so we start out with bishop and
rook against knight and rook
until takes on e1
and so in this position already
there's actually a very important
decision
for white to make and it might seem
kind of innocuous whether we take with
the king or the knight
but white already needs to think about
how they want to arrange their pieces
so let me ask you guys which piece would
you take back on you one with
with the king or the knight
and why
yeah so getting a few answers
yeah the night is correct
yeah and very good manny with the exact
reason
so this is the thing the knight
absolutely needs to find a good home
and this knight on c2 is actually very
clumsy right these pawns are doing a
great job of restricting all the squares
it would like to go to
so the correct move for white would have
been to take on e1
now when black moves the king up the
knight immediately jumps to f3
and this knight is going to find a very
good home on e5
had white played this the knight would
have actually been very strong
the night knights more than any other
piece love outposts they love active
squares where they are stable
and this knight on e5 does an excellent
job covering the king side
covering the d3 and c4 pawns
and white's king can manage the queen
side
so it was paramount it was crucial for
white to activate this knight
now when we do this there's one question
we have to check right when we bring the
knight up like this we have to ask
ourselves what if black decides to go
into a pawn end game
and if he does all right what's the
result here
this kind of thing can be tricky to
evaluate so this is why to understand
these more complex end games
it's actually really important to
understand with an unders with
pawn end games right with simpler
positions the ones you can reach because
if you can't evaluate this
you can't really evaluate the minor
piece in game
so in this position we have an equal
number of pawns
yeah black has a queen side majority
white has a kingside majority
the way i would the way i would evaluate
this position as black though
is that when we go a6 right we try to
use our queen side majority
white goes a4
and if we want to make a pass pawn on
the queen side
either we need to get our king to c6
or we need to sacrifice with b5 which is
very dangerous because white gets a
passer
so suffice to say black can't actually
do all that much on the queen side the
pawn structure is pretty bad
in the meantime though white can make a
pass around the kingside with h3 and g4
so this position even without evaluating
it exactly
as black i would be pretty confident
here that the only person that could be
in trouble
is me if anyone's going to lose this
it's going to be black
and that's really all the information i
need black can actually
yeah so black can draw if they defend
the king side carefully
by keeping their king over here
basically keep it in check
i won't go into the exact details
they're not relevant during a game i
wouldn't think about it at all whether
or not i can draw this as black
but knowing that i can't win this that's
all the information i need
to know that taking this is nothing
special
so because of that whether or not black
takes white snite can jump in here
and i mean honestly this night the
bishop's a little better than the knight
here for reasons i'll get into
but the knight is such a strong piece
there again managing i would say 75
percent of the board
or 75 of the files that
it secures a pretty comfortable draw
so yeah the best plan for white
was to improve the knight immediately
right knights need good squares
they need outposts and this knight on
this c2 square
not only is it not good it's not really
near any good squares either
in the games miso took with the king
and as we're going to see this one
mistake
this one pretty innocuous looking
mistake
causes him a world of hurt in fact i
think it's it's already either the game
losing move or very close to it
because now the question is where is
this knight going to go it's aliko's
king f8
he's preparing to improve his king maybe
use it on the queen side
and in the meantime what is white going
to do right
yes mislove took with the king
unfortunately for him if he hadn't we
wouldn't be talking about this game
ironically
but again we're going to see it's
surprising just how much trouble this
gets weighed into
so in the game he goes king d2 so
perhaps this is why he took with the
king he wanted to cover the queen side
as quickly as possible
and underestimated the importance of the
knight it may have been time trouble
they hadn't hit move 40 yet
so but that might be why he just wanted
to bring the king to the queen side to
cover these pawns
so the question is what if smithslav
the importance of this maneuver what if
he realizes just how important it is to
improve this knight and goes king f2 now
right and sometimes this is a good idea
right sometimes if you realize your
mistake
it's important right to go back and fix
it
you know if this is still a good
maneuver so be it it doesn't matter if
your king just went to e1
but as it turns out unfortunately for
white it's already too late
black goes a6 here
and if white goes 91 black goes b5
so after knight f3 right if white
insists on this plan
blacks gained a couple tempe on the
queen side
and these proved to be crucial
now let me ask how would you play this
out as black let's say you take
yeah this is lost time and
the simplest way there's a few good ways
to play this is black actually
but the one i like best is you just play
b4
the thread is to play a5 a4 and make a
password
if the king goes to the queen side to
cover it something like this
yeah right a5 b4 there's no way for
white to make progress
so white's king is perpetually tied down
to these pawns and now black has all the
time in the world
to break through on the kingside to have
any hope of drawing this white needs to
set up a fortress
like this
white tries h3 oh i'm sorry
sorry this is actually the wrong
maneuver
sorry here white does have the fortress
messed up
now so this would be good sorry this is
good in another line when the position
is already opened king g6
the problem is let me show you
after h3 if you could already play h4
i'm sorry
you would win yeah you play h5 if black
plays h4 you break through
and this is a win but white plays h4 and
this is actually the fortress i was
talking
about
so the key for black sorry
is to take on c4
you and now you have this open line on
the queen side to use
the key is overall that these extra
tempi are very useful for black
and the queen side situation has changed
dramatically
i see you take sorry you do have to as
you just saw you have to be very careful
that you don't miss a fortress very very
careful especially in this position
where there's this many locked pawns
similarly if white takes and goes knight
f3
again you have to check this end game
it's worth looking at it for white to
see if maybe you can improve the knight
this way
but this time again black can take and
this time there's really no hope of a
fortress right the queen side's wide
open
and here actually the easiest way for
black is you go h5
and now the difference here is because
of these queenside pawns if white goes
h3
let's say white goes h3 and g4 now
let's say white goes for the same
maneuver with this different queen side
how do we win this position as black
what does black do in this pawn in game
now
you have to be a little careful because
let's say
if you take in c4 if you just trade off
pawns
white takes and the king is still in the
square the king still covers the pawns
so here why it's okay the key is you
want to make a threat with your pawns
that white can't answer
and i think you guys are on the right
track you want to make them past each
pawn
so this time you take and you go h4
this time because of the different queen
side situation
this g4 is no good for white
right black's pawn goes to h4 and now
whatever white does let's say white
tries to push these pawns
now you go c4
and you're going to have a pass d pawn
and a past h pawn white can't stop them
both
c4 immediately in this case
the problem with c4 immediately is white
can do something like g5
stabilizing the king side and then after
c3
white's king is still in the square so
this white could draw
against a king in particular you really
want these split pawns
you really want to split up passers
because the king can handle one thread
easily
when you split up the pawns like this
and make two threats that's how you win
the game
yeah so again you have to calculate
these things very carefully that's part
of why these end games are so difficult
but sure enough this pawn in game is
winning for black
the queen side is too strong and if
white doesn't play g4 if white doesn't
do this
and let you get the queen the king
marches up you play c4
you're gonna get a monster
so all in all the overall conclusion
from this is it's too late
for white to recant his mistakes the bad
setup
even if white realizes now that this
knight needs to get to e5
and there's a couple of you mentioned
miso besides being a world champion
right is a famed endgame player
and the fact that he made this one
natural move that turns out to be a
mistake just shows you just how
difficult this position is
so smooth goes to d2
right consistent with his previous move
he wants the queen to guard the queen's
sorry the king to guard the queen side
and then he figures as long as he can
keep the kingside
under wraps no it might be worse the
bishop might be better than the knight
but he can still hold it with a fortress
and we're going to see it takes some
absolutely world class play
from 12 to
break through this strong idea of sweet
slopes
so he goes king e7 white goes 91
all right we're seeing the problem now
this f3 square
is unusable
yeah so it's kind of funny actually just
how clumsy this knight is
it only has two plausible paths through
a3 to b5
which is easily stopped by a6
and since f3 is covered through g2 to h4
which is just not that great a square to
begin with
so this just goes to show how important
it is to recognize the danger early
because you'd think that this knight
would have some way out right some way
to get to e5
but these lock pawns actually these
these black pawns do a great job
restricting it along with the bishop
so telugu is king e7 91
and now a6
so tell us looking for queen side play
now
right you have a great position
yeah you have a great position but you
actually have to win it right
you can't just say my bishop's better
than that you have to undertake some
active play
so tell seeking to use this majority
and play b5 and basically start creating
threats on the queenside
and here white has a very difficult
decision to make
white can either allow b5 right after
which black can for instance target c4
with the bishop
or if white takes black gets some very
mobile pawns
or white can try and prevent b5 with a4
both of these still leave white in
serious trouble
it's doubtful that white could save the
game in either case
but all the same i mean it's just a
difficult decision
that smeslov has to make in the course
of the game
so after a3 b5
right bishop f7 is probably coming next
so at some point this structure comes
and black can look to invade on the
a-file with his king
so it's created another weakness
in the games mislove decided to play a4
and at first this looks like a huge
mistake a couple people have mentioned
this actually a4
at first it might seem like it runs into
something right isn't this pawn loose
what if black just plays bishop b8
and here's a question this isn't very
natural looking move bishop b8
is actually a huge blunder
anyone see how does white punish this
move
any ideas
this you can't save the apon but you can
do something very strong here
yeah so step one is a5 a5 is very
important
you're losing a bun but you're doubling
black's buns
so black's pawn structure really hasn't
improved at all right this extra pawn is
worth very little
and after a5 what does white do
the problem is this bishop e8 is
actually a tragic mispositioning of the
bishop
which means that finally white gets in
knight f3
and knight e5 and the king can manage
the a pawns
yeah so this would actually be tragic
from black because it lets white
it lets white fix the earlier blunder
the king can still manage the a pawns
even if there's two of them
and because the bishop has slung to e8
instead of
h5 black hasn't gotten enough on the
queen side to justify letting this
knight in and white can draw
so bishop e8 is premature here
instead decides to leave the pawn as is
for the moment
instead of win it and plays a5
so now white does have king c2 so
white's in time to save the pawn
but now it's a perpetual weakness
why not b5 instead of b takes a5 this is
a good question
bishop e8 a5 if you try to play b5
instead
it's not a bad idea trying to keep your
pawn structure good
but white still goes knight f3 and
whether you take on c4 or play b4
again white gets knight e5 with a
complete fortress
right the knight covers the c4 pawn and
the potential g4 weakness
and black simply has no way in
so this end game is very tricky and
we've seen a couple times already what
the potential cost is of
a seemingly innocuous mistake
so instead a5 king c2
and now with this pawn structure strong
now losing the a4 pawn would be a lot
worse for white
so now actually now only now that he's
played a5
now until it goes bishop e8
the difference being if white goes
knight f3 now
black can take on a4
and he's one upon again but this time
the pawn's on b6 instead of a6
and this makes all the difference
because now he's going to play b5
white doesn't have this defensive
defensive fortress he had before
and black's going to have two useful
extra pawns on the queen side
so by playing a5 first
black has created a completely different
situation on the queen side
so instead after bishop e8 knight f3 is
not good enough anymore
and white has to go king b3
and what do we do here is black we've
drawn the white king to b3
but what is it very important to do
right now
right yep someone pointed out the bishop
goes to c6
and this is really a beautiful square
for the bishop
not only does it cover target the a4
pawn and keep white's king on perpetual
defense
but it still takes away the f3 square
i mean this bishop on c6 is an absolute
monster controlling two of white's
pieces
but in spite of all this play in spite
of the masterful peace handling we've
seen from taos
the silt is very close to being a draw
because on the queen side we have a
fortress at the moment
the white king is stuck defending a4 but
it's still a fortress
and the king side is very very close to
being a fortress
right if if black plays h5 and white
plays h4
then there's just no way in it doesn't
matter how good black's bishop is
if you can't make progress that would be
an example of an in-game fortress
so black must tread carefully
so instead of that black has one entry
to white's position
so first he aims his king at g4
if the king gets here white has no king
side defenses
and the king's just going to take all
the pawns
so white's forced to play h3
but okay this is a minor concession but
as we're going to see it's crucial
just getting the knight to b5 help
anything
it might it might not be the worst
square the problem is it can't even get
to b5
so let's say right let's say here white
decides to bring the knight to b5 after
knight c2 black goes bishop f3
and after knight a3 again trying to get
to b5
there's bishop d1 check already
right white can't afford to lose the a4
pawn so the knight has to come back here
and white still doesn't get to be active
in b5 it's not great it might be an
improvement certainly over e1
but it's not even in the cards
so smithslav just keeps spiding his time
with the king there's not really
anything else he can do
tal as i said brings the king to h5
right threatening to invade
on the king side
and forcing h3
so king g6 and now the next question is
how does black actually make progress
here this is probably
i would say the trickiest part because
black's position right again this bishop
looks so dominant but there's no way in
at the moment
white's actually established a total
barrier
so now we have to figure out how do we
crack up how do we
put a crack into white's position how do
we
how do we create some pressure how do we
create a new threat that white can't
answer
we have to do something here
zuke's one would be nice at the moment
it's not realizable because the king is
shuffling
all right yeah i see it yeah so the key
is white's created this new
light square weakness the king can't get
in the king's locked out
but the bishop cam there's no barrier
against the bishop
so first tala moves his king out of the
way then yep as was said
the bishop is actually going to target
this pawn
and the bishop is heading over
so for only this white gets another
chance
to bring the knight to f3
it looks very strong but unfortunately
again it's no longer good enough
and this just goes to show how close
this end game is because white keeps
being inches away from setting up a
fortress
this time after knight f3 black goes
bishop h5
knight e5 black checks on d1
king a3 black covers the b6 bomb
from knight d7 by playing king d6
and funnily enough white's about to get
in zigzag
all right the king is now tied to a4 it
has no moves
and if white tries to move the knight
around you just go bishop c2
and h6
and white's completely in zigzag right
the night side to this pawn
the king's tied to this pawn
now one one last thing white can do is
g4
but black plays bishop d1
and again white can't move the king it
drops a4
white can't move the knight it drops g4
and if white does something on the king
side
like this now black's king is getting in
easily
all right going to take going to win the
h pawn
and race to glory
so now white can't afford to allow this
and this is why towel can get away with
allowing knight e5
and you can see just how precise he has
to be in this end game yeah just how
good this maneuvering is
and for me this is an extremely
borderline end game that would have been
very easy to mess up at various points
and that just goes to show that despite
his reputation as an attacker which is
well deserved
because he's a monster just what a
clever player tal also was in the
endgame
so after bishop b8 so if knight f3 the
the black bishop invades here and zig
zong's white
so instead he goes to g2
after bishop h5 the knight's not
attacked
so white has a tempo to go king c2
right just covering this bishop d161
idea before it can happen
okay so no bishop d1 but black executes
its original idea
which is to target this h3 weakness
and funnily enough i mean this again
just goes to show how clumsy the knight
is
if we just move the knight to f2 so
regarding these two light squared pawns
black could just play king b3 or sorry
white could just play king b3
and everything would be guarded it would
actually be a trivial fortress
and in spite of how passive white is in
spite of the weak light squared pawns
there would actually be no way but the
knight on g2
just isn't good enough even the knight
on f2 would be so white goes 91
and bishop f1
yeah so targeting h3 right kind of the
one weak point that white hasn't been
able to manage
so if h4 there's an easy route for the
king into the position
knight f3 and this is a nice try from
smithslav
because now when black takes white does
get knight g5
so white's getting the pawn back but
crucially what's much more important
than the pawn
is the fact that black's king now has an
inroad now there's definitely no
fortress
bishop g2 and white takes on h7
so after bishop e2
couldn't white just play knight so
knight h4 f3 g1
and then just shuffle the king
so after knight h4 what's the play after
bish knight x4 there's bishop f1
and again black is winning this pawn
so you don't have time if you could get
to g1 maybe you could make a fortress
that way
but there's just no time to do it
so instead white goes for this trade
knight g5 bishop g2 takes
here now the king is getting in though
after king g6 white does have knight f8
and knight d7 this is actually still
winning for black after king g4
but tell didn't want to allow this
counter play
so instead of king g6 he goes king g7
it's more patient but he's correctly
judged
right it's a little slower he's
correctly judged that there's no way for
white to prevent this entry
to prevent this invasion of the king
now instead white has to go to g5
and the king starts heading for g4
and now now white's position just has
fatal weaknesses
at this point there's no hope for white
to have a fortress
at this point white might as well go for
counter play which
mislove correctly does
so he goes king d2 and telugu is bishop
c6
all right so smith is saying i'm going
to give you this pawn
after king c1
the tall actually realizes if he takes
on a4
this lets white's knight get back to e5
which sets up the kingside fortress
again and this is actually win
at this point black's improved things
enough black has the good pawn structure
on the queen side this is actually
winning
but again like that last like that last
counter play i showed you with the
knight coming to d7
the same as that case tall realizes i
don't need to allow this
he's playing this end game very very
precisely
completely restricting white's counter
play while improving his own position
and he goes back to g2
another trap to note if he goes to h5
immediately
it tells on his toes white has a clever
move knight f7
and again the king is stopped because
after king g4
white has 95 forking the bishop
so here white would actually get 95 and
again and this is still winning for
black at this point
black's position is strong enough that
you could get away with this but all the
same
it's it's just it's a good policy right
not to allow counter play you don't have
to
so he goes bishop g2 king up and king h5
right without the bishop on c6
there would be no fork here
so now the king is invading at this
point there's nothing white can do to
stop that
so smith's love correctly judges well
okay so again instead of going for a
pure defensive play
which might be promising if there were a
fortress if white's fortress were a
little stronger that would have been the
way to do it
but here the fortress is clearly
breached and smithsoft correctly goes
for counter play
knight e6 and knight c7
so the knight's coming to d5 and he
wants to start taking these queen side
pawns
right these pawns worked well with
black's bishop right light squared
bishop likes having pawns on dark
squares
but the one downside right one major
downside is the bishop can never defend
them
so white so white will start getting
these queenside bonds
there's nothing to be done about that
well he'd start getting b6
but we'll see tall goes bishop c6
and he realized that even after knight
d5
you can't take because this past d-pawn
would be very strong
another pawn end game it's important to
judge correctly
but after king g3 this bishop is very
well placed
if white takes on b6
the bishop is perfectly placed to stop
future attacks on these bonds
so this was some nice prophylaxis by
thal
so instead of that so smithsoft goes
knight e7
he shook back knight d5
and he could have taken the pawn
immediately
but after tapes takes
bishop e8
white's managed to hold on to this f4
pawn because after knight t5
black wants to be careful black doesn't
want to take the knight because then
he'll create this past d-pawn that's
very dangerous
but instead
instead he's going to stick to the minor
piece end game
and use this a pawn so the knight is
doing a good job it's covering f4
but white has two more weaknesses right
two more problems in the position
this a pawn that the king has to deal
with now
and this weak d3 pawn
so if white plays passively here black
will just push the a pun
and while the king goes and wins it
black will just raid these weak queen
side pawns
so again white can't afford to sit
passively he can't hold the position
together
smithslav realizes this and correctly
decides to go for counter play
so smithslav goes knight c7 bishop
right the knight's going after c5 it can
go two different ways
there's no way to stop them both
so the knight is getting the c5 bone
and again you have to judge these things
carefully
but as we're going to see the the cost
of getting the c
pawn is that white's losing the f-bomb
and again white has two problems so
after a3
he draws the knight to b3
if white goes with the king instead
black can take
and king e3 and even though white gets
material equality
both white's pieces are completely
misplaced and the pawn just runs forward
to victory
so instead after a3 white goes knight b3
so the knight is stopping the a pawn
but as i mentioned the knight's been
diverted from d5
and that means the f pawn is a goner
so black goes a2 again there's no rush
to take the pawn white has no way to
defend it
if white wanted we could win another
pawn
and technically white retains material
equality here
but after knight b3 simplest for black
is just bishop up
white has to go knight a1 to keep
guarding the pawn
and again the contrast between pieces
and the contrast between pawns is huge
black just goes king g3
white's knight is tied to this apon the
bishop is still doing a good job
controlling white's pawns
and the f-pawn wins the day
so that's the problem right these two
bonds fundamentally cannot both be
managed by white
so instead white sends the king after
the a pawn
black takes on f4
king b2 and king e3
and kind of similar to the line i
mentioned earlier white's gotten to the
a-pawn they can grab it if they want
but now white's just in no situation to
deal with the f-bomb
so one more time white goes for counter
play
at this point it's pretty clearly too
late
but it's a good try for smithslav he
goes knight a5
retreat the bishop
and c5
yeah so this is a good way of going i
mean you might as well try for something
right if the fortress doesn't hold
you need to at least create some threats
or you'll always lose sooner or later
yeah there's a few other great end games
like this another end game i highly
highly recommend
that i actually strongly consider doing
for today instead
is a fischer time enough it's bishop and
six pawns against knight and six pawns
and very similar to this actually
taimanov had close to a fortress
it looked very hard for fischer to
invade but fischer does some brilliant
maneuvering much like tall in this game
actually with his bishop and king
and eventually sneaks into black's
position by sacrificing his bishop you
know
yeah it's that game's from the fisher
timing off from their candidates
quarterfinal
highly highly recommend that game if
you're looking for another bishop
bishop beats knight in game
yeah so in this case again jumping back
black is broken down white's fortress
so white tries to go for counter play
with the pawn
and here it's all actually goes for
minimum
counter play at this point
you realize that you could just go f3
after c7
right the bishop is a good defender it
covers c8
you just have to check that after knight
c4 check
black can go king e2 all right be a
little careful don't take on d3
and fall for this fork although funnily
enough
black's position is so strong that i
believe even that is
that even that may be winning but okay
so king e2 bishop stops the pawn
the spawn's a queen
i believe that end game was game four of
their quarterfinals
game two was another famous bishop
versus knight actually
fisher had bishop and pawn against
knight and taimanov blundered a drawn in
game
it's also a good one for study but game
four i believe is the really beautiful
fischer time in off game
but okay so smith goes for c6
f3 wins as we discussed you have to be a
little careful
it's all just takes
and you do want to be careful giving up
material
you because you never know white does
stop the f-bomb
it's worth noting right the f pawn is
not becoming a queen so
you do want to be careful right
evaluating these end games
because if it weren't for these pawns
this would actually have been a terrible
blunder
but in this case he goes f2
white has no choice but to give up the
knight for this pawn
check and king e2
and after white takes on a2 this is
another end game worth knowing
after king e2 if you have the pawn on
the fifth like this on your opponent's
half of the board
and you win the pawn in front it's
always winning
so after king e2 black's going to win
the pawn
and actually get the queen immediately
so tall read all of this very well and
actually it's mislove seeing
this resigned after f2
it's a very very well played end game by
tall
apart from king takes e1 the initial
mistake we talked about song
there aren't really any significant
blunders i would say by smithslav he had
a couple alternatives
right a couple of slightly different
ways he could have defended the position
a3 instead of a4 for instance
but none of them i think would have
saved the game so to me it's a great
this is a great example of two things
right just how good tal was at the end
game
he has a reputation as an attacker which
is well deserved of course
but he was a very very good all-around
player as you might imagine a new world
champion is
and the fact that
smithslav i'd say who is also an endgame
maestro as a couple of you have
mentioned
managed to go wrong with one pretty
innocuous looking move
shows just how much respect the end game
demands
all in all again this is one of my
favorite end games because it's just so
well played
and it's so borderline too between a win
and a draw right we saw
how minor the mistakes from black could
have been that would have given white
not
just a draw but an easy draw
yeah and again it's yeah fischer it's
all an endgame strategy
that's a tough question they were both
absolute monsters
again that fisher time and off game game
four of their quarter finals
is another master class that that you
should look at
yeah so next week i'm going to cover the
reverse side of this
i'm actually going to cover knight
versus bishop
the famous karpov kasparov game where
karpov does a pretty beautiful pawn
sacrifice
and to win again another very very
difficult very close to drawn end game
of knight against bishop
so i hope to see you all for that next
week i hope you enjoyed this lesson
and thank you all for watching